hey so today I'm having a Mario Kart 8
party so obviously I must decorate for
said party and that's what I'm gonna do
right now okay
oh my Mario guys we're gonna need you
all to assemble toad tari sack boy you
have nothing to do with this party time
to decorate mashallah both Mario's I've
got these decals mmm
gonna be awesome chocolate old-school
Mario
[Music]
[Applause]
it's coming along nicely
yeah Mario we typically we G chillin
looking great looking great you look
great you look great
look at this you were cooking some beans
right dedicated chef here today at the
Mario Kart party cuz guess what I can't
do look you even have a Mario Samsung's
ring guys I haven't actually had needs
in probably was this like two Mike am I
gonna poo my no no you good say no I
didn't eat me for two years and I ate it
oh yeah it was the best thing ever
alright well here goes I'm gonna eat
this burger Lamar
meet you I would have Marisa's yes
yesterday are you giving this to me no
do you want one are you gonna have to go
over here for another year and a half
that bun looks real wig yeah okay I'm so
excited about this oh this is um I mean
his mom we are now gonna start the Mario
Kart 20 tournament all right oh okay
Johnny okay I'm just making sure
look at his little patch of fur I know
of non first receiver you baby Mario oh
oh you okay baby Mario big Mario yeah
that's a good car that will you meet me
enjoy Justin one more source Mesa and I
won yeah no joy be so many things went
wrong and any time we say joy and Joey
it keeps running together it's like Joey
cheese like who are you looking like
Joey and Lamar bling I'm not playing
since I'm 16 I want to talk about what
happened because Lamar beat me I and
unfriend him on every social network so
now
I'm fine first before you unfriend okay
okay okay this can happen so the finals
are up here it's joy against Ryan come
Francesca's here your bana whiting yeah
ed what happened why did you know it was
that make sense you know sleep oh my god
define over desk come up big human body
all right so good luck to both of you